Angela Merkel tritt demnächst ab als
Bundeskanzlerin ist nur noch
geschäftsführend im Amt und sie ist
wirklich sanfte Presse gewohnt gewesen
viel Applaus dabei beruhte meiner
Meinung nach ein Teil zumindest ihres
Erfolgs primär auf den Erfolgen der
Agenda 2010 von Gerhard Schröder den wir
heute als Gazprom Gerd bitte stehen
müssen aber diese Agenda hat das Land
fit gemacht die Kanzlerin wurde immer
gut behandelt eine legendäre Frage die
mir dabei in Singen kommt ist die eine
schon alliston an die Kanzlerin es
stellte ist sind sie eigentlich im Amt
zur Frau geworden ja so sanft wäre
sicher jeder schon mal gerne angefasst
worden dabei wäre es viel besser gewesen
die Journalistinnen und Journalisten
hätten harte Kritik geübt denn die
Bilanz von Merkels Zeit ist bei weitem
nicht so positiv wie man das vielleicht
vermuten würde oder wie es auch heute
noch dargestellt wird das Land und die
Gesellschaft sind gespalten weil der
Coronavirus voller falsche Angaben und
Entscheidung war wir haben gerade
darüber kochen auch Angela Merkel die
Kanzlerin selbst hat letztes Jahr um
diese Jahreszeit gesagt es wird sich nun
von Monat zu Monat verbessern wie
enttäuscht sind die Leute die jetzt
bemerken müssen es hat sich gar nichts
verbessert in der Regierungszeit von
Angela Merkel ist neben ihrer Partei
ausgerechnet rechts davon eine Partei
entstanden nämlich die AFD weil sich die
Union unter ihr regelmäßig
opportunistisch nach links bewegt hat
Antisemitismus grassiert in Deutschland
eine Schande für dieses Land von der wir
uns eigentlich ein großes nie wieder
geschworen hatten auch deshalb weil in
der Migrationspolitik nicht darauf
geachtet wurde ob vielleicht viele
Antisemiten ins Land kommen Migration
geschah nämlich unkontrolliert darf half
den Bedürftigen oft nicht so sehr wie es
notwendig gewesen wäre und verunsicherte
teilweise bedrohte es sogar Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in der Folge wuchs auch der
Terror massiv in Deutschland und den
Opfern hat Angela Merkel viel zu selten
gedacht ein anderes Thema die Umwelt
belastet Stand ist verheerend weil die
Kanzlerin
S8 und nach überstürzt aus der
Atomenergie ausgestiegen ist nämlich
wegen Fukushima wären Japan das
betroffene Land dort weit hinauf
Atomenergie setzt die Meinungsfreiheit
ist wenn man Umfragen Glauben schenken
darf dia von sehr seriösen
Meinungsforschungsinstitut und kam auf
eine Minimum angelangt viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger haben das Gefühl nicht mehr
sagen zu können was sie denken und vor
allem ist Deutschland mittlerweile zum
Ende der Regierungszeit der Kanzlerin
eines der am wenigsten digitalen Länder
alle Industrienationen weltweit DSL ist
langsam wir stecken in den 80ern Venture
Capital gibt es viel zu wenig die
Startup-Szene ist unterentwickelt
außenpolitisch hat sich Merkel zwar
immer sehr gekümmert wir haben eine
raustragen des denn Ding auch dass es
selbstverständlich anzuerkennen aber die
chinesische macht die weit im Osten
entstanden ist die Deutschland mehr und
mehr dadurch bedroht dass sie einfach
wirtschaftlich hier sehr stark
investiert und gleichzeitig massiven
Menschenrechtsverletzungen begeht für
die von die Kanzlerin zwar immer Mann
der Worte aber ganz selten die klare
Kante die schon längst nötig gewesen
wäre mein Fazit ich glaube im Nachhinein
wird man diese Kanzlerschaft deutlich
negativer beurteilen als man es während
ihrer Zeit getan hat
dass wir das heute tun aber ich finde
Angela Merkel auch in der Finanzkrise
der Eurokrise viele Nationen haben uns
auch um sie beneidet ich will es noch
mal eine große Reform die Angela Merkel
gemacht hat die vielleicht vergleichbar
wäre mit der Agenda 2010 ihres
Vorgängers es ist natürlich so dass
Angela Merkel auch stark von von der
Agenda 2010 von Gerd Schröder profitiert
hat aber man muss auch sagen wie viele
Krisen sind zu bewältigen hatte das
genauso. Angela Merkels Politik und
Regierung Stil war gib mir eine Krise
und ich regiere und werden einige
richtig aber diesen hatten die
vorangegangene Bundeskanzler auch immer
der Punkt ist nur was mache ich
eigentlich immer keine Krise ist und
gibt es eigentlich Leitlinie die ich
habe gibt es eine Reform dich anstoßen
muss Thema Rente Sozialsysteme steuern
und da fällt uns und du hast kalkerfeld
und eigentlich will er
natürlich zu
10 bei einer Reform die extrem für
Wachstumskräfte reingesetzt hat dir die
Arbeitslosigkeit halbiert hat davon hat
Angela Merkel aktiv profitierte wenn man
dann mal schauen was eigentlich in dem
Bereich in der Amtszeit von Angela
Merkel passiert ist ist doch gar nichts
damit er das Blatt Reiseformen erstens
die Schuldenbremse ist eingeführt worden
im Grundgesetz unter Angela Merkel
zweitens die Rente mit 67 sie haben
gerade gesagt Rentenreform die Rente mit
63 ist die SPD die Rente mit 67 war sie
und wir hatten Unternehmenssteuerreform
ich kritisiere auch hier ich finde das
Bild was sie zeichnen wo er nicht
differenziert genug ich bin auch als
Reformer in die Politik gegangen ich
will Aufbruch und wirre Formen für die
nächsten 10-15 Jahre da muss mehr
einfach kommen auf der anderen anderen
Seite internationalen unglaubliche
Phänomene und mit der Schuldenbremse und
der schwarzen Null Politik konnten wir
uns diese Wirtschaftshilfen leisten
gewählt haben Helene das erkenne ich
alles an es ist auch nicht so ich habe
ja öfter auch mal gesagt zum Teil ne
also es ist nicht so dass ich die ganzen
16 Jahre für verheerend halte überhaupt
nicht sie war sicher auch eine große und
wichtige kannst drin ich kann auch deine
Emotionen verstehen also nach 16 Jahren
da wird uns wirklich was fehlen aber
ein. Hätte ich ja noch hinzufügen können
sehen Celeste eine vollkommen zerstörte
Volkspartei man weiß ja gar nicht wieder
ihn weitergeht und ich hatte jetzt auch
nicht den Eindruck da können sie uns
vielleicht aus dem Innenleben noch mehr
schildern dass sie sich jetzt wahnsinnig
um ihre Nachfolge bemüht hätte dass sie
sich da konstruktiv eingebracht hat und
jetzt schauen sie an wo sie stehen die
Regierung ist weg sie wissen gut 40
Mercedes werden aber die wissen gar
nicht wie es ihr Führungspersonal ist es
ja ganz vieles weg vielleicht gehören
Sie künftig dazu oder sie tun ist schon
ja aber das ist ja noch ein Punkt den
ich hätte anfügen können absolut wir
haben uns muss man hinzufügen den Angela
Merkel festgebissen hat Funktionshose in
einem heimlichen dir mit Edmund Stoiber
im Jahre 2002 der dann zu Street auf den
hinter Benken saß und immer wieder
versucht jetzt an die Spitze der Partei
zu kommen und immer wieder bis er
erinnert wurde von Angela Merkel oder
ihren Truppen mal gucken ob es jetzt
klappt ob er gebrauchen sind quasi als
letztes Trojanisches Pferd der
Bundeskanzlerin ist doch noch schafft da
einen Keil in die 3 in 1 zu bringen aber
bleiben einmal bei dem was bleibt man
fragt sich natürlich was wird das
Etikett der Bundeskanzlerin ein sein
nach diesem 16 Jahren die beständige die
schweigsame hihi klar denkende oder nach
vorne agierende letzteres bestimmt sich
und einmal zu diesen Krisen
Finanzkrise an der Seite von Peer
Steinbrück wurde das Versprechen gegeben
eure Spareinlagen sind sicher aber das
war wichtig gemeinsam Gutes vorgebrachte
die zweite Krise war Fukushima und wir
sollten nicht vergessen dass es Gerd
Schröder waren ein Atomausstieg
hingekriegt hatte bis 2030 in einer
Phase wo ist natürlich gelungen wäre
alternativen Energien entsprechen
aufzubauen Angela Merkel und ihre damals
FDP Koalitionäre haben damals die
Atommeiler Laufzeiten verlängere Licht
zurecht und nach völlig
Rechtsanwalt Aalen Baden-Württemberg wie
man hofft dennoch irgendwie zu gewinnen
habe gesagt raus da aber ganz schnell
und die Konsequenz ziehen wir jetzt wir
sind nicht vorbereitet für den Umstieg
wir sagen mit Ökostrom soll es
weitergehen aber keiner weiß woher der
Strom kommen soll mal soviel zu Bilanz
über die flüchtlingskrise können den
ganzen Abend reden und was die uns sehr
hier beschert haben durch ein wirklich
schlechtes Management bis heute wirkt
das nach also eine Bilanz die sicherlich
mehr Schatten hat als ich kann sie ein.
Die Partei ist zu wenig selbstbewusst
gewesen hat sich zu wenig emanzipiert
auch vom Kanzleramt und die Partei muss
eigentlich immer einen Schritt weiter
gehen und du kannst nicht nur aus dem
Kanzleramt regieren die Energiewende
fand in der Partei als Debatte nicht
starte oder wie wäre das bei mir auch zu
wenig ich hätte mir stattdessen
vielleicht ein Lichtjahr für alle
gewünscht vielleicht wirken zumindest
die Debatte führen müssen auf der
anderen Seite waren wir ja mit nachher
noch auf deiner Seite haben wir ja mit
Angela Merkel Wahlen gewonnen und wir
haben uns auf sie konzentriert aber sie
war oftmals das einzige Argument und
ansonsten haben wir es vergessen und
versäumt in der Sache die Unterschiede
zu den anderen Parteien zu suchen dann
sind. Sie sind ja jetzt auch das ist ja
auch zum Teil nicht ganz viel weil sie
Blitzableiter wert sind als an CDU CSU
Fraktionsvize sitzen sie hier sind aber
jemand der ja mit Friedrich Merz
zusammen für einen Aufbruch eigentlich
stehen will und wie schlecht es um die
Partei steht hat ja auch Friedrich Merz
selbst zu des öfteren gesagt also das
hat er ja auch bezogen noch mal auf die
Pandemie und und seine Worte waren ganz
klar im Interview über sich ja auch mit
ihm geführt haben vor einigen Monaten
nur ganz versagt die Pandemie hat ja
gerade die Schwächen Deutschlands
exemplarisch offengelegt und das ist am
Ende auch kein gutes Haar was er an der
Regierungspolitik von Angela Merkel
lässt muss man das Versagen das Thema
Atomausstieg ist 1 da stimme ich
überhaupt nicht überein was Gerhard
Schröder und die Grünen gemacht haben
ganz klar Johannes woher hat ja gerade
auch angesprochen mich würde auch
interessieren bei Ihnen die Frage
Atomausstieg muss das eigentlich wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden müssen wir
Maila länger laufen lassen